the moral compass of the Republican
Party could not possibly be better
illuminated than by Matt Gates
interviewing George Santos slash Anthony
De volder slash Anthony Santos slash
George devolder whatever name you know
him by I'm talking about the liar who
was elected to congress he appeared on I
guess Matt Gates's show I didn't even
know Matt Gates had a show but I guess
he does on real America's voice
and the interview is like nothing I have
ever seen I don't know who thought this
was a good idea the pressure is building
on George Anthony Santos de volder to
resign I don't know that this interview
is going to save him but you have to see
this here is George Santos saying he has
lived an honest life I've worked my
entire life I've lived an honest life
I've never been uh accused shoot of any
bad doing so that's untrue he is
actually been accused of crimes in
Brazil already and there are multiple
criminal investigations but okay that
that's a lie so you know if he's lying
about not lying right now before your
very eyes it's my it's the equity of my
hard working self and I've invested
inside of me like I said didn't come
from he invested inside of himself deep
deep inside of himself and he found that
he is an honest man Charisma it didn't
come for Ukraine Russia China unlike
some folks that we all know that get
money from those sources yeah
um okay so then Matt Gates asks him
where did your campaign funding come
from and he again repeats this cute
little line one of the principal
critiques I've heard is that a lot of
money uh was donated to your campaign by
you 700 000 I believe where did it come
from well I'll tell you where it didn't
come from it didn't come from China
Ukraine or barisma how about that
well yeah that that is an answer that is
not actually an answer we finally
figured out the funding actually came
from
uh what was that country Trump made up
nambia
um it's not an answer and he is being
dis this interview is to prove how
honest he is and he can't stop lying or
or obscuring the truth during this
actual interview here's another moment
during which Gates says listen sure you
embellished your resume but everybody in
Congress has embellished their resumes
we'd have no one in Congress if
embellishing your resume got you kicked
out you have admitted embellishing your
resume you've acknowledged it you've
apologized for it uh some have said that
you shouldn't be seated on committees
for it I would offer that if we didn't
see people on committees who embellish
their resume running for congress we
probably wouldn't be able to make Quorum
in any of those committees uh other
people embellish so everything's fine do
you do you uh now have a sense of the
Committees you want to serve on the type
of work you want to do I came to DC
Without Really any preconceived notions
of what committees to serve yeah he came
to this DC without any preconceived
notion about what the hell the job
entails whether what I can give to the
American people whatever committee I'm
given whether it's I don't know science
and technology or education and labor or
whatever committee is thrown my way I
will deliver 110 because that's what I
know how to do I'm going to outwork any
of the pundits and Talking Heads pundits
the word is pundits pundits come on dude
that are out there saying that I should
resign that I'm unfit for office the
reality is and the and the the the the
the the the the case and point here
being is I'm a Workhorse I've worked my
whole life I'm the kid who came from a
basement Department you weren't supposed
to win this season I was not supposed to
win this season yeah so Matt get I don't
know how Matt Gates ended up doing this
Rehabilitation attempt of George Santos
Anthony devolder and
um on the issue of resignation
here is what Santos had to say I I wish
well all of their opinions but I was
elected by 142 000 people until those
same 142 000 people tell me they don't
want me uh we'll find out in two years
what are those 142 000 people deserve in
a representative they deserve somebody
who's going to come here and fight and
not get involved with the media nonsense
that we're seeing take place right
nonsense now here's the problem
the 142 000 people
voted for a person that doesn't exist
and what I mean by that is they voted
for a fictional character who was a
volleyball star at Baroque College
who worked in High Finance who had
degrees that he doesn't really have
who's Jewish in a and the reason it's
relevant is it's a it's a district with
a significant Jewish population and he
told stories about his Judaism
it they voted for someone that doesn't
exist and so to say well they now don't
get a say until two years from now
because they already voted for him they
voted for someone who is not the person
actually representing them so Gates is
now sucked into it we don't know what
exactly is behind Gates doing this
interview but what is stunning
is that these are softball interviews
these are meant to be interviews so easy
that they make him look prepared and
honest and qualified and forthcoming and
all these things
he obviously and brazenly continues to
lie in interviews designed to be easy
for him to at least pretend to be an
honest person let's hope that he's gone
by Monday although Anything Could Happen
make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel we are pushing for 2
million YouTube subscribers this year it
is early on in the year and uh
youtube.com the David Pacman show is the
place to hit that subscribe button
doesn't change anything doesn't cost
anything you're just saying I like what
you're doing YouTube recommend this
stuff to more people that's essentially
what you're saying I'll give you an
update on uh the progress towards 2
million probably late next week